- If you do wrong things
mainly harming other,
you get negative consequences.
Some say something good
person, some say bad person,
it doesn't matter so long my
own motivation for thinking
is honest, sincere.
When we investigate the reality,
our mind should be calm.
The basis of genuine friendship is trust.
Trust depend on openness.
- He's a monk of the Yellow
Hat school of Tibetan Buddhism.
He's currently the 14th Dalai Lama.
In 1989, he received a Nobel Peace Prize.
He's the Dalai Lama, and here's my take
on his top 10 rules for success.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'm curious to see which one
you guys like the best.
As always, as the Dalai Lama is speaking,
if he says something that's
really inspiring to you,
make sure to leave it
in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
(upbeat music)
- The ultimate source of
satisfaction within ourself.
- If you do wrong things
mainly harming other,
you get negative consequences.
If you do helping other,
bring more happiness to other
you get benefit.
More inner strength there
and more sort of confidence
of purpose of life
and fulfillment about that purpose,
then you always feel happy.
If the rest of the people
really feel that me
as a politician or
further a bad politician,
then I feel sad.
(laughter)
Or a cunning, liar politician
then of course, no problem, no problem.
Some say something good
person, some say bad person,
it doesn't matter so
long my own motivation
for thinking is honest, sincere.
That's the important.
That's simple Buddhist monks.
Actually, Buddha as he taught.
Don't care what others saying.
If one say too much
praise, then at that time
should think, Oh, I also have the critics.
Then, one say a lot criticism,
then you should think,
Oh, some people are praising me.
So, it doesn't matter.
Too much sort of paying much attention
these things are silly.
Ultimate source of happy life
is our inner value.
So therefore,
irrespective of a believer or nonbeliever,
whether it be religion or not.
See, we should pay more attention
about our inner world.
Now scientist,
according latest of scientific findings,
it now sort of clear,
even good health or healthy body,
the healthy mind is very essential.
More peaceful mind
brings healthy body
because mind calm,
peaceful, then our body element
also then remain more balance.
So that brings healthy body.
Too much stress,
too much worry,
disturb our body element.
That creates certain sort of problems
in what is body.
So therefore, calm mind is very essential.
I think you should realize that anger
may bring some kind of energy,
short moment, for a short period.
But that energy is actually blind energy.
And anger really destroy
your part of your brain which can judge
right or wrong.
So when we fully develop anger,
we can't see the reality.
So that energy, more bold, right?
But that energy is blind energy.
So in order to face the problem,
our method should be, as I
mentioned earlier, realistic.
In order to carry realistic method,
you must know the reality.
When we look the reality,
when we investigate the reality,
our mind should be calm.
Otherwise we cannot see
the thing objectively.
So in order to use human
intelligence properly,
our mind should be calm.
So taking this line anger
is firstly destroy your inner peace.
Secondly, destroy your ability
to investigate the reality.
So you think this way,
then once you have clear evidence,
anger is no use, only destruction.
Affection, or compassionate attitude,
warmheartedness,
is very, very important
for one's own well being,
for one's own happiness.
So don't consider practice of compassion
is something religious matter,
or practice of compassion
is something good for other,
not necessarily to oneself.
That is totally mistake.
So, since from childhood,
we already equipped
this seed of compassion,
we learn from mother and ourself
in order to become parent,
the seed already there.
Now that seed, you must keep,
nurture all our life.
The biological factor
compassion is limited,
biased, and more dependent
on other's attitude.
Now that as a seed.
Then using reasons, evidence,
that seed of compassion,
can further develop
unbiased compassion.
Not depend on other's attitude
but rather other's being itself.
So that kind of compassion
can reach your enemy,
or entire sense of being.
So that compassion is infinite compassion,
unbiased compassion, real compassion.
So if we become compassionate person,
then your life become meaningful.
Because you yourself happy,
calm, peaceful,
your friend, including animals,
also should get peace.
So at the last day of our life
you feel happy.
All my life,
I'll spend
peaceful, friendly.
You really feel happy.
Otherwise, at that moment,
even you're a billionaire,
ghost money, nothing can be used.
No matter, what good cause of a good body,
a beautiful body.
All everything have to leave.
So at that time, I think
genuine satisfaction
can bring if your whole life
spend more compassionate life,
then you feel no regret.
So purposeful life is
naturally happy life,
meaningful life.
So in order to make meaningful life,
ultimately, warmheartedness is to give it.
Then another important
factor is determination.
And you should not think these development
can take place within a
few days or few years.
We must understand.
You see that these developments
even may take eons.
(laughter)
So you see our determination,
if you consider as a Buddhist
and one who really
practice the Buddha dharma,
then right from the beginning,
you must, you see, make up your mind,
doesn't matter even may take millions
of billions of billions of eons.
It doesn't matter.
After all, what is the
purpose of our life,
the meaning of existence?
Nothing.
You realize something positive.
Then, you see, even days and month or eon,
it is meaningful.
If you really wasting a
life, the purpose of a life,
then even one day too long.
So once you determined,
once you make up your mind,
some kind of firm determination,
and clear to objective way,
then time is not important.
(speaking in foreign language)
It is so long space remain,
so long sentient beings
suffering remain,
I will remain in order to serve.
You see that sentence really gives me
some kind of understand,
and also I think inspiring.
So the more impatience,
and as I mentioned before you today,
want something the quickest
or best or something,
then I can reserve all the Buddhist idea.
(laughter)
The quickest, cheapest method,
it is seldom will be Buddhist.
So you see that's, I think, wrong.
So that I would like to share with you.
So that's where I use it.
I myself also recite this as a mantra,
or as some visualization
or certain mandalas.
But in my daily practice,
although my practice very poor, very poor,
but even then I admire the main emphasis
on this form
and Bodhicitta,
and koruna.
So that really I feel
is something practical.
Then through this practice
you will get something practical benefit.
Visualization was big in the 80s.
Sometimes I think they
cheating oneself
almost like this like
this is cheating oneself.
- [Monk] Deceiving oneself.
- Deceiving oneself.
So therefore,
I think, you see, we must receive practice
step by step
with patience, with determination.
Once you involve, are dedicated,
or determined to practice,
then some improvement you can see.
You see year by year or decade
by at least decade by decade,
then you can see oh, at least some change,
some improvement you can see.
Once you see that, that
also gives you some kind of
- [Together] New encouragement.
- So, to change, not easy, not easy.
When we feel a sense of irritation,
during that moment if that person
concentrate fully on the breathing,
nothing else,
breathing, one, two, three,
like five, 10, 15, 20.
When you start bringing,
mental state irritated.
But then after 20, 30, sort breathing,
your mental state will
be little different,
little more calm.
Since we are dealing with emotions,
so the best method to deal with that
is through the so-called mediation.
Not for next life, not for Heaven,
but for day to day's well-being.
- [Host] Do you believe
that your time here
on earth has been a success?
- Success?
That also relative.
Some field
I think some achievement there
and some field, failure.
So, difficult to say.
I know all human life like that.
Some part failure, some part achieve.
(laughter)
It is wrong to pick up
one thing, then say,
"Oh, very success."
Is wrong.
And pick up one thing,
failure, that also wrong.
Things are relative.
We are social animal.
We human beings, social animal.
And particularly, in modern time,
the reality, economy,
environment, and many things
heavily interdependent.
That is reality.
Unlike I think
past is sort of ancient time.
Ancient time all this
independent, self-sufficient,
as in not dependent, your
interest or your future
not depend on other.
Now completely changed.
So even from this selfish viewpoint
you have to take care
about others' well-being.
You just think of your self,
blind selfish, think for
yourself, forget other,
or worse thing, exploit other,
cheating other, bullying
other, ultimately you suffer.
Through these mischievous way you may gain
some temporary sort of
benefit but deep inside
you feel uncomfortable.
Then eventually, you truly
become lonely person.
Nobody loves you, nobody respect you.
If you take care of other,
as a human brother or sisters, sincerely,
seriously, then everybody
become your friend.
So when you have truly
trusted friend there,
if you need something you can ask them.
If you becoming friendless
or lonely person
and when you really facing some problems,
nobody you can share.
So ultimately, we are social animal.
So even other animal,
no law, no education, no religion,
but you see,
they have some kind of sort of feeling.
Their own individual survival depend
on rest of the community or herds
so they work together.
I am one of the individuals
out of seven billion human being.
If human being, rest of
human being happy, peaceful,
I get much more benefit.
The rest of the world get trouble.
How can I escape from that?
And with that feeling, when I meet people
one people or one person or 10 people,
100, 1,000, 10,000, 100,000.
I always consider them as
my brothers and sisters.
That brings me in mental
level completely relaxed.
If I feel I am something
different from them,
then some nervousness,
something inside me may develop.
So once your own way of thinking open,
reach out then as a close friend
that tremendous sort of
benefit, peace of mind.
Then others also feel
no longer feel stranger.
Another human brothers like that.
So that I think, which really
nowadays, we really need that.
So through that way, awareness.
Then from children, I think
youngsters, I think they know
just one child remain lonely may cry.
And play with other
children, feel very happy.
So that's the human nature.
So sometimes we grown-ups,
then we always calculate
if I make friendship with that,
how much I get some benefit.
(laughter)
Or make friendship then I
can exploit or something.
Then, the genuine basis of friendship
no longer there, destroyed.
Basis of genuine friendship is trust.
Trust depend on openness.
So, through these things we can change.
And then, mental level, no
matter what your physical level
busy, but mental level always
calm, restful, relaxed.
Immense benefit for your health.
So mental health, body
health, very close link.
So the ultimate source of mental
health is warm-heartedness.
That's my belief, maybe wrong.
My friends have to research,
more research work.
When I was young
I had some different birds.
So, one small parrot.
He met one city official.
The feet of that parrot.
So therefore whenever that busy person
approach to that parrot,
the parrot always showing
some very excitement
or something like that.
Then the official usually gives him nuts
and then while the parrot is
eating, the official's finger
you see on the head of
the parrot go like that.
Then the parrot position
special, friendly attitude.
So I developed some jealousy.
(laughter)
So I also want that kind of
response from that parrot
so I'm developing.
(laughter)
So therefor you see you must show
the model of that friendly.
(laughter)
Poor animal you see do not know that.
Anyway, anyway, I try to develop
that kind of a friendship, so a few days,
I tried to give some nuts.
Then that parrot take the nuts
then showing very negative attitude.
(laughter)
Then I lost my temper.
I used some thin stick
to discipline,
discipline the reaction.
So after that, no hope make friendship.
(laughter)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because Saring Cholesto
I hope I pronounced
that okay, asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave it
down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why,
what change you're going
to make in your life
or business after watching this video.
Leave it in the comments,
hold yourself accountable,
and I'm going to join in
the discussion as well.
Thank you guys so much for
watching, continue to believe
in whatever your one word
is and I'll see you soon.
- The important isn't that
different emotions are right,
different emotion.
This is the ultimate enemy
or the source of suffering
and also that is a different emotion.
Once it develop, it's in our mind
and immediately it
destroy our peace of mind
and eventually destroy our health
and also to destroy our
friendship with other people.
So all thee negative
activities, such as killing,
bullying, cheating, all
these negative actions
come out of this different emotion
so it is real enemy,
it is the destroyer of our
peace, destroyer of our sort
of fortune and including our health
so therefore that's the enemy, real enemy.
External enemy today may be harmful to you
but next day be very helpful.
But this is inner enemy.
Always an element as destructive.
and more when enemy
wherever you live, always there.
External enemy we can put some difference
on also you see, like as 59, we ask it
so we can ask it.
But this enemy, even when they in Tibet
or they in Putala or they in Damsala
or they are here in the event London.
Wherever I go, this enemy there.
Even I think some go to meditation.
Some use the visualization of mandala.
Still, in the very center of the mandala
that enemy still there.
So this is the point now.
We have to realize that.
Sorry, this is the real destroyer
of our happiness, always there.
How to do now?
If there is I would say, no possibility,
just to work on that, to eliminate that,
then I can better forget
and I think I like more
alcohol, sex, all these
things much better.
If there is possibility to eliminate that,
then I think now we must
take this good opportunity.
This is human body, human
brain, human good heart.
Combine these two things, try.
It's to reduce that and
to eventually eliminate.
So therefore, they call
it a Buddhist teaching.
Our human body is precious, why?
Because of human interests
and the de-shaping or changing our mind,
not only through our emotion
but mainly our intellect
cause of intellectuals, reasoning.
And there are two kinds of emotion.
One emotion without any
reason, just as a feel.
Such as if they're headed on these things
of course we have some
reasons why this person
is very sort of angry on me
and then through that kind
of analyze, you develop.
But in deep down, the further goes,
it's not what you see reasons.
So it's the easy motion
without proper reasons
devastate negative emotion
and the other kind of emotion
such as is compassion,
altruism a kind of emotion with reasons
and a further investigate, you can prove
there's something good,
there's something necessary,
something useful.
So their kind of emotion
is all the time of emotion
but very much relative to that.
Very much go well with
reason or intelligence.
So the combination
intelligence and emotion,
that is the way to change,
to change our inner world.
So to that also I think
the basic fundamental
second nature
so long that enemy there
so long we are under that enemy's control.
No permanent happiness.
So once you develop some
kind of desire to overcome
that enemy, now that is the.
- [Monk] That is the true realization
of the aspiration to seek freedom.
(speaks in foreign language)
Which is technically called renunciation
in the Buddhist language.
- So, you see
this practice
the analyze our emotional level
and our inner world
is the very important
as the key practice.
Then I think the best method
to avoid fear or regret
at the time of death
is while we are alive,
our time our energy must
utilize meaningful way.
That's the most profound way
of meaning of usefulness.
One's own survival, even
animals also this can do.
But for service to other is something
unique about human being
and I think bondage
where mother and child or offspring.
- [Monk] The bond between
the mother and the offspring.
- Bond even other animals also have.
But that kind of closeness
feeling short period.
But we, human being,
because of intelligence,
that kind of feeling we can
prolong whole all our life.
- [Monk] Yeah, extend it through our life.
- So, serving other people,
helping other people
is I think very, very
appropriate sort of action
according our intelligence
or human ability.
We have such ability so
to utilize that ability
- [Monk] In the most appropriate way
- Most appropriate way
is serving other people.
Then, at the end, you feel no regret.
I done my best some useful
sort of meaningful life.
Now end come, although
sorry, sad, but no regret.
So mental level of experience
and sensory level of experience.
Mental level of experience
are much more serious.
Obviously,
we ourselves have experience.
When our mental state happy, calm,
our physical pain can subdue.
When mental state too
much pain, too much worry,
the physical comfort cannot reduce,
cannot subdue.
- [Monk] No, reduce.
- The mental state sort of pain,
so obviously mental state
is more serious.
So therefore,
now including medical science,
more and more now scientist in that field
now realize mental state
is very, very important for our health.
So, in meeting with scientists, our slogan
How to Create Healthy Body, Healthy Mind.
So, healthy mind very much
related with healthy body.
So healthy mind, you see, cannot produce
by medicine or alcohol or drugs, no.
More illusions there.
So it has the mind.
Also it can not produce buy injection.
Cannot buy from supermarket
so therefore the healthy mind must develop
within the mind from faith
some extent, but no.
The real change in mental level,
certain condition.
Genuine conviction come only through
research investigation.